all over yeah and uh now
there's only one square that the rook
can move to and it's just to
step in front of its king not good
step in front of his king no and i'm
just look to okay
i didn't even see that's possible i
assumed uh hugh fan would choose this
square
for her rook um so it was impossible
to go after white's pawn there because
black's bishop was trapped in the corner
black had to move that bishop but now
there's a there's tactics
there's tricks yeah white is now
attacking that black bishop that black
bishop has no safe squares
huyfan now has to just give up her
bishop if she takes that white pawn
white's rook will slide across one
square
and pin that bishop but if she moves
that rook that bishop from the diagonal
hey
what's going to move the rook two
squares up and uh well that's it
she resigns about to lose her bishop who
you fan gives up
it's uh over magnus carlsen getting a
win
um after losing the first game magnus
carlsen is back with a win
in the second game